[Music]  Kylie Jenner showed off some new bling  on Wednesday in honor of two of the most  important people in her life her man and  her bestie I love it  the 20 year old reality star took to  snapchat to post this shot of a custom  yellow gold band with tiny diamonds in  the initials JW from 14 carats in  Beverly Hills I'm obsessed with it the  beauty mogul explains the meaning  writing Jacques Webster and Jordan woods  real ones okay Jacques Webster is the  real name of Jenner's boyfriend and baby  daddy Travis Scott the couple welcomed  their daughter stormy in February after  months of speculation about Jenner's  pregnancy et caught up with the 20 year  olds famous momager Kris Jenner on  Wednesday night in LA and she revealed  how her youngest daughter is doing one  month into Parenthood  [Music]